on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and our censored one
of the most fascinating and
controversial polemicists on the planet
Dr Jordan Peterson's books became
overnight hits Millions watch him online
and his tools pack theaters across the
world he's a clinical psychologist whose
fans pretty more like a rock star and
tonight we go Toe to Toe and most
definitely uncensored
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London and
welcome to a special edition of Piers
Morgan on censor Dr Jordan Peterson one
on one
he's a clinical psychologist turned
culture Warrior at one of the world's
most famous and Infamous intellectuals
his books are instant bestsellers tens
of millions watch him online Legions of
fans sweared by his straight talking
guidance what I've recommended to people
is clean up your room but his outspoken
views on issues like feminism The Taming
of the wild man essentially by the by
the desirable and virginal woman and if
you think women don't want that then you
better bloody well come up with an
explanation for 50 Shades of Gray and
gender you won't use my pronouns so I'm
pretty sure you're my enemy yes yeah
well I know you think that but I don't
believe that using your pronouns is
going to do you any good in the long run
I've made him a lightning rod for
controversy almost 40 million people
have now seen this notorious interview
with a British news show you're
exercising your freedom of speech to
certainly risk offending me and that's
fine I think more power too as far as
I'm concerned so you haven't sat there
and
I'm just trying I've just tried to work
that out I mean
ha gotcha it's nobody friends face
criticism just for meeting him he's
loved he's loathed but he's never
ignored and tonight Jordan Peterson is
uncensored
well Jordan Peterson joins me now John
Peterson welcome thank you to Piers
Morgan on a sense that's my first
question and there will be people
genuinely wanting a simple answer yeah
but there's a bigger answer too who is
Jordan Peterson well I'm a clinical
psychologist and a professor and I'm
doing that on a broader scale now I
suppose and but it's an extension of
what I've done since
1987 really I mean I I taught the same
things I'm teaching although I've
expanded them
all throughout my academic career and my
classes were very popular and and not
popular exactly
they the students found them extremely
useful why have you become so notorious
because I I look at it as I've actually
watched a lot of your lectures I've
listened to hours of you and Joe Rogan
talking about stuff
I don't see the devil that some people
try and portray you as at all and it
seems to me the one thing we may share
in common is certainly not intellectual
prowess where unfortunately I've many
yards behind you but what we do show I
think is that a lot of people seem to
have drawn an opinion about us based on
either what they've seen in a tiny clip
taken out of context a lot of the time
or what they've been told to Think About
You by other people yeah well that's
some of it I mean I got tangled up in a
political controversy in Canada I've
been tangled up I put my foot in it to
some degree because I wasn't very happy
with what I regarded as Government
overreach in relationship to who is in
possession of my tongue and I decided a
long time ago and really a long time ago
that I was going to say what I thought
and sort of independent of the outcome
you know often people craft their speech
you know I could come here on your show
for example I spent half an hour
thinking well what do I want out of this
show but I don't think like that I
wanted to come here and have a
conversation with you you don't actually
make notes on top before you're big I
made notes but I generally don't use
them so I have to prepare you know are
they different when you go on tour is
every night different yes yeah I never
do this how do you decide what to talk
about
well at the moment sometimes I'm taking
questions from the audience and so I
just do a q a but I don't look at the
questions before I go on stage and I ask
my wife who asked me the questions not
to show them to me and then if I prepare
a lecture I usually have a question in
mind often that relates to one of the
topics in my books but all but sometimes
something I'm thinking about and then I
use the lecture as an opportunity to
explore that question and answer it well
I'm watching the audience to see if my
words are landing and so it's an
opportunity to think on my feet and I
think part of the reason the lectures
are
are well attended is because it's a high
wire act in some sense because I never
know when I go on stage whether I'm
going to bring the lecture to something
like a punch line to something like a
conclusion so and I have no idea because
I'll have a variety of ideas up in the
air nothing extraordinary you have no
idea where it may lead to no
no no it's an exercise it's a little
scary I mean
yes
but you know there's an idea that the
truth will set you free right and and
that's a very strange idea because you
could imagine that I could come here and
I could decide there are things I want
to do to promote my books let's say and
I could tilt our conversation towards
that or I could just say well I'm going
to pay attention to what's going on here
and I'm going to see what happens and
I'm going to say what I think and then
I'm going to assume that whatever the
outcome is is the right outcome because
it was based on something approximating
the truth what is your ultimately what
is your goal what is what is the point
of Dr Jordan Peterson what do you hope
to achieve through what is now huge
Global Fame
um I hope to encourage people other than
that I want to see what happens you know
I want to say what I believe to be true
as clearly and
and carefully as I possibly can and I
want to see what happens as a
consequence and what people don't
understand about that in some sense is
your happiness the purpose of your life
is not going to be happiness sometimes
it is
sometimes that will come but there will
be difficult periods in your life and
happiness won't suffice that but what
you can have in your life is an
adventure you can have an adventure and
the truth is the best adventure there's
no doubt about that and there's a couple
of reasons for that one is you don't
know what's going to happen if you say
what you think now I don't mean in
cautiously and I don't mean
provocatively or any more than necessary
you don't know what's going to happen so
that's very adventurous but also if it's
you and your voice then it's your
adventure and if it isn't like if you're
crafting your speech or manipulating in
any way or parroting or abiding by the
dictates of the crowd
then I don't know whose Adventure you're
having but it's not yours on Free Speech
it seems to me in my 57 years of being
on this planet the Free Speech has never
been under more ferocious attack not in
places you would expect like
authoritarian regimes but actually in in
democracies I never thought I'd come to
a day in my lifetime where people were
literally being fired or in some cases
imprisoned for expressing honestly held
opinions even if I find those opinions
grotesquely wrong or offensive you know
it's worse than that people
underestimate the significance of this
because it isn't we're not having a
fight about who has the right to speak
freely that's nothing that's that's
that's a peripheral problem even though
that can be serious in and of itself
we're having a fight about whether or
not your claim that Free Speech exists
is nothing but a masquerade for your
willingness to dominate and use power
and so if I was taking that attack I'd
say it's all well and good for you to
speak about Free Speech but look you're
white and your middle class and you're
British and you're and you're privileged
and you have this theory about free
speech that your ancestors drive but the
only reason they ever derive that to
begin with is so they could exercise
their power there's no such thing as
free speech that's just a lie to mask a
power claim and that's a way worse
cynical criticism of the notion of free
speech then you can't speak because I
don't agree with I mean it's a form of
fascism isn't it I mean these people
it's worse than that the kind of the
ultra woke uh Brigade out there they
they categorize themselves as liberals
but there's nothing liberal about that
mentality when you have a canceled
culture which is driven by if you don't
agree with what I say you're going to
get shame vilified canceled fired maybe
even in prison that is actually what
fascist regimes do to people to their
yeah but the fascists are more
straightforward about it because they
basically come out and say something
like shut up or we'll beat you right
whereas the compassionate types
who are narcissistic compassionate
compassionate types they come out and
say well we're really trying to save the
world you know and we're we're acting in
everyone's best interests and we think
it would be better if if you should just
you know regulate what you say because
if you don't you're not you're not a
good person
and so that's it's much more I'd take
the fascist bully over the narcissistic
over the compassionate narcissist
anytime they're way more straightforward
I mean we live again in an era where the
hashtag be kind yeah yeah almost
invariably is used by people who are the
least kind people I think I've ever
encountered yeah there are people that
love to be utterly vicious yeah what
kind of idea they hide behind this fake
persona of hashtag be kind yeah yeah
well kindness is tricky you know because
one of the things you deal with very
commonly if you're a clinical
psychologist apart from depression and
anxiety is well Behavior therapists
offer assertiveness training and now the
people who need assertiveness training
are all often people who are too
agreeable compassionate polite by
temperament now the problem with that is
that they let every other they let
people walk all over them because they
don't they don't stand up enough for
themselves and the consequence of that
is they get resent full and then they
get bitter and then they get conniving
and then they get and then they'll mob
and so because they're not
they'll do anything for everyone else
but
they push themselves beyond their limits
and they and then they won't even
recognize the limits because they feel
well if I'm not doing everything for you
then then I'm not a good person it's
like no a good person does a little for
you like if I'm acting properly with you
say in this conversation there's
something in it for you and there's
something in it for me right and we want
that to be reciprocal and so the cost of
me bending too far in your direction is
that I'll become bitter and resentful
and conniving and and that and
resentment is non-believably toxic state
of being it's like a short break I want
to come back and talk to you about what
a random collection of people Cristiano
Ronaldo the most famous footballer on
the planet the greatest in my opinion
and also Olivia Wilde who's made a movie
in which she said it's about you because
you're the guy the bad guy the drive
some of the worst human beings on planet
Earth yeah we'll talk about all those
things after the bromance
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored one-on-one with
Dr Jordan Peterson so a weird thing
happened uh about two weeks ago I was on
Instagram and something unpop this
picture
and it was you with a friend of mine
Cristiano Ronaldo the the Football
Genius greatest player to ever play the
game as far as I'm concerned and you'd
be to see it uh just privately and he
was saying how great it was that he'd
met you and you'd gone there and all
hell broke this he was bombarded with
people saying this is outrageous Legend
over Legacy finished none of which would
have bothered me because he's heard all
this kind of thing before but the Venom
of it was from certain quarters were so
pathetic it seemed to me so first of all
what were you doing with Cristiano why
why were you there well he invited me to
come and see him and um he had had some
trouble in his life a few months ago and
a friend of his sent him some of my
videos and he said he had watched those
and then he read my book or one of my
books and found them very helpful and he
wanted to talk so I went out to his
house and we talked for about two hours
and he showed me all his equipment for
keeping himself in Tip-Top condition and
we talked a bit about his companies and
but mostly we talked about what he
wanted in the future and some of the
obstacles that he's facing while
pursuing that and so we had a strategic
conversation I would say for for about
on those topics for about 90 minutes
were you in a way we either the Ted
lasso figure in his life well that's
what it felt he didn't realize he was
missing yeah well I think maybe he did
realize that he was missing it because
he seemed to have found it to some
degree in those lectures and so and I
was I I always like to hear not only
what people are up to but what they want
and I one of the things I loved about my
clinical practice which was very much
predicated on this like well you're
miserable let's say not to say that he
was because he has a good life in many
ways but
if you could Envision a path forward out
of your misery let's say to somewhere
better what would that look like and
it's not a question people ask
themselves with enough depth and then
having developed that vision
what are the strategies that might be
put in place to make that more likely
and again not in a manipulative way but
if you had to conduct yourself in the
proper manner to bring about this
desirable end or at least to move
towards it how would you how would you
organize your behavior when someone like
Cristiano who you know we know what the
personal problem was he'd lost a baby he
and his partner was incredibly sad for
him and professionally after that a lot
of turmoil as to whether he was going to
stay at his club and so on and so on
um it seemed to me talking to him in the
last couple of days after he saw you
he's in a much better place actually
that's what happens when you hang out
with reprobate like yes but really
interesting to me so you've got and you
and he both got criticized for just
seeing each other
um but actually it was clearly very
helpful too well I hope so that would be
lovely if it was true
it's a weird position isn't it there's
you Dr Jordan Peterson this guy that
comes out of Canada lecturing students
and then you're at the home of the
greatest football player of all time and
you'll genuinely helping him I mean
Ronaldo is known as one of those
mentally strong athletes has ever been
yeah right not just physically but
mentally strong and yet he needed
someone like you to help him I find that
really fascinating well I don't know if
he needed me because he's a pretty
competent guy but but you know you can
always and this is something that very
competent people do you can always
improve on the edge you know and so his
life is very well put together and he
had some trouble but people do but we
talked a lot about what he wanted how he
wanted his career to end in in the most
graceful possible Manner and how that
might be optimized and so I hope you
told him very well to sign for Arsenal
in the January transfer window did you
Jordan no I didn't give him I don't give
try not to give people advice I mean I'm
curious on that because he's obviously
reaching not not the end of his career
by any means he's still a world-class
player and he's incredibly fit so he
could play for another three four years
perhaps but what is an end game for
someone who's achieved everything in the
game yeah well it that's a good question
it's hard for people who who have had a
stellar career especially one that's to
some degree predicated on youth to
figure out what to do with the rest of
their life now he's well set up because
he's a very canny businessman and he has
a young family and he has lots of
friends and as far as I could tell on
that front he's situated himself
extremely intelligently so I think it
looks to me like the transition for him
is going to be quite smooth so but
that's a testament to his wisdom because
he made sure that his life was
was founded on more than one dimension
of of attainment and that was very wise
does it make you feel good that even
people like him confine great Solace
from watching your lectures
well all that makes me feel good I mean
I do think that this is part of the
reason I keep going on these lecture
tours is that seems to be doing people
good so let me ask you about
um
kids what you done by kids I mean young
adults really and then into their their
20s trying to form their way through
life one of my favorite movie clips is
Rocky Balboa it's probably the
non-intellectual version of Jordan
Peterson in many ways because he said
this to his son he was getting a bit
spoiled and entitled and moaning about
being Rocky Summers on and he says this
to him
let me tell you something you already
know
the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it you
me or nobody is going to hit as hard as
life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how when it is done
now if you know what you're worth to go
out and get what you're worth but you
got to be willing to take the hits and
not pointing fingers saying you ain't
where you want to be because of him or
her or anybody
cowards do that and that ain't you
you're better than that
I love that speech yeah it's good what
do you think of it well that ethos was
what lifted up
Sylvester Stallone to start him very
rapidly with his first movie and what do
I think about that I think that young
people are literally dying for that
message I really and I mean literally
they're so demoralized it's just beyond
belief and so one of the things that's
been painful about what I've been doing
with my wife as we've traveled around
the world for the last number of years
is to see how desperate people are for
an encouraging word
let's take a break and find out what
that encouraging word should be I want
to know why a lot of young people are
very anxious about life why is that and
what's the best way for them to come
through it yep we'll deal with that
after the break more from Jordan
Peterson
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to the special edition
of Facebook one-on-one with Dr Jordan
Peterson we left them on the Cliffhanger
with Rocky Balboa and his address to his
son about how to grow a pair for one of
the better phrase
um this idea that actually your life is
defined not So Much by success because
you're everyone's friend when you're
successful but by The Knocks you were
never to be going to get whether it's
through losing loved ones losing a job
you know losing a car whatever it may be
you're going to get hit by blows in your
life of differing magnitude and I've
always believed that how you deal with
the downside of life really defines how
you lead the rest of your life well the
clip is very interesting because it
starts out with the admission that life
is brutally difficult and sometimes
unbearably brutally difficult and and
you can see the progressive playing with
that notion it's it's it it's warped
into this sense of victimization but it
does does reflect some understanding of
the underlying tragic reality of life
and so it's good to get that right on
the table to begin with say well you're
miserable you have your reasons and they
might be deep reasons but
if you let the misery demoralize you and
make you bitter and cynical and cowardly
and make you withdraw then first of all
that's a failure in the highest Sense on
your part and all it's going to do is
make everything worse and then you might
think well what do you have
to to to respond to that how do you
respond to that
catastrophe and Challenge and the answer
is and this is what Rocky is telling his
son in no uncertain terms it's like
terrible as things are there's a lot
more to you than you can possibly
imagine and that if you face those
things forthrightly and with some faith
and courage then you can you can you can
have the adventure of your life and
Prevail even over catastrophe and that's
true right I mean I I couldn't really
get my head around why so many young
people feel so anxious all the time
compared to when I was young when it
just that wasn't really a big thing
amongst my friendship groups certainly
but I I reckon there's two things one
social media uh the constant bombardment
of other people having a great time or
looking great often of course imagery
and like having to live up to full-size
deals but also the conversation I
haven't Dr Phil in America where his
explanation for it was that he said
you've got to understand that social
media means that young people now are
being bombarded all day long and all
night long with quite shocking imagery
and he gave an example he said when I
was young he said if a crocodile ate
somebody on a golf course in Florida the
chances are I would never have heard
about it it probably wouldn't have made
the national news probably wouldn't have
even made the state news and I wouldn't
have heard about this incident now it's
quite likely that a video of the
crocodile eating this person would be
whipping its way around social media
within half an hour and young kids will
be sharing it disseminating it and being
exposed to this constant imagery all the
time of quite unsettling and shocking
imagery what do you think of that theory
and that well I think that in itself was
adding to a sense of everything's
terrible well I think it's a corollary
of an information overload Theory right
I mean one of the advantages to having
to having the computational power we
have is that everything is at your
fingertips and the disadvantages that
everything's in your face and by
everything it might be 40 million
pornographic images like that's a lot or
an endless array of tragic scenarios and
really endless and so that's a problem
and the problem the fundamental problems
how do you handle the fire hose of
information and no one really knows the
answer to that but we should also point
out that it's no wonder that young
people are demoralized and anxious
because we're doing everything we can to
demoralize them and make them anxious so
on the masculine front we we tell young
boys that while the world's a terrible
patriarchal tyranny and all of that
patriarchal tyranny which is the whole
explanation for history has done nothing
but press and exploit people and destroy
the planet and so that any manifestation
of that masculine impulse on your part
is equivalent to the world destroying
Force when all masculinity now is
branded toxic yeah and I remember I
think that the key moment from becoming
Gillette who'd always had these very
masculine commercials with the big guy
cuddling a baby or whatever it may be
they suddenly switch gears and did a
campaign where it started with a lot of
metoo imagery and basically the
assumption that all men are awful until
they can prove otherwise and I predicted
in a column this would be a complete
disaster for them and sure enough nine
billion dollars later they did a
screeching U-turn and went back to the
big guy cuddling the babies because
actually two things I think about that
one most men are not awful actually and
so not all the time oh no some better
obviously um some women are pretty awful
no but not most of them but you try
saying that and not getting canceled um
but I think also this thing that you've
got into trouble about which I don't
understand why that you believe that
most women
probably quite like their men to be
strong and confident I don't believe
that all the data shows quite clearly
about cultural samples and has for 50
years that's everywhere anecdotally most
women I know I think would absolutely
agree why is it that you've been so
vilified
for suggesting something which is so
palpably true well I think first of all
that annoys narcissistic women no end
and it annoys people who thinks that
think that there are no biological or
cultural limits on how we manifest our
behaviors and also it frightens a large
number of women because many women have
never had a good relationship with
anyone masculine in their life and so
the notion that they would need to
establish a trusting relationship with a
man especially if he's also in something
approximating a superordinate position
which is much what they might like to
find him maximally attractive also
implies that they're in some sense going
to be under his Sway and if there's no
trust there well that's absolutely
terrifying and I have some sympathy for
that because there are no shortage of
women out there who've never had a
positive relationship with anyone
masculine and so they're very they're
completely unable to discriminate
between
narcissistic power and compulsion and
confident competence and so because they
can't distinguish that and they're
afraid they put all of that in the same
category which is something like the
Predator category and and that's not
good for them because well as you said
all men aren't Predators all the time
and they need to establish relationship
with the man right we're also in a very
strange place where a lot of
high-profile women
will not say what they think a woman is
yeah because they are a potentially
Brown Jackson the new member of the
Supreme Court in her nomination hearings
was asked the question this is what she
said can I provide a definition no yeah
I can't
you can't
not in this context I'm not a biology it
was a riveting moment because you're
like you're going to be on the Supreme
Court of United States of America
you're a woman you're the first black
woman on the court and that in itself I
know you've raised eyebrows about why
did Joe Biden go out there and say we
need to have a black woman why not to
say we want the best person available
and then if she's the best person get
her on the court which I completely
agree with but for her not to be able to
commit to explaining what she thinks a
woman is and then I had a moment on this
show where Macy Gray the singer did
stick her neck out and she said this
I will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman just because you
go change your plots doesn't make you a
woman right sorry
you feel that I know that for a fact
like if you want me to call you her I
will because that's what you want but
that doesn't make you a woman because I
call you or her I just because you got a
surgery
with chilling predictability Macy Gray
stuck to her guns for a couple of days
and then the onslaught was so
overwhelming against us she had to go on
National Television in America
issue a groveling apology for everyone
that she'd hurt with this statement of
what many would think is just a
statement of biological fact
we got to this place where women are
terrified of saying what a woman is and
women who do say what they think it is
I.E they're a clear biological
distinctions between a man and a woman
they get destroyed well we've accepted
this Preposterous hypothesis that your
identity is only subjectively defined
and as I've tried to point out on some
of my lack in some of my lectures
the only people who think their identity
is subjectively defined are
two-year-olds and I mean that
technically because two-year-olds are
egocentric which means they can't bring
their identity in alignment with a
social Norm which also means that
two-year-olds can't play with other
children they can play beside them but
they can't play with them that doesn't
happen until you're three what happens
when you're three if you're reasonably
well socialized or start to move towards
that is that you learn how to negotiate
a social identity and then identity
becomes obviously it has a root some
roots in your subjectivity and in your
biology for that matter but a
sophisticated identity is not only
socially negotiated as the
constructivists know perfectly well but
it's also it's got a dynamism about it
because it has to be constantly
renegotiated like as we're having a
conversation here to some degree we're
renegotiating our mutual identities
because we learn something from each
other right so we transform right we're
also trying to figure out to some degree
who each of of us is in this situation
and then we're also trying to learn can
we play together towards some productive
end and you might ask well what do you
mean play and say well we're trying to
have an interesting conversation let's
take a little break I want to come back
and talk to you about the royal family
in this country and the huge seismic
moment in history we've just had a
little pieces not to break again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
part with Dr Jordan Peterson the royal
family and the death of this great Queen
an extraordinary outpouring of love and
respect not just here but around the
world actually biggest event of his kind
I think I've ever seen what did you make
of it what do you think of a monarchy in
the modern Asia is it survivable
well I thought that what happened was
extremely interesting psychologically
because Queen Elizabeth stood for or
embodied a whole set of Virtues which is
the right way of thinking about it that
aren't in the least bit fashionable but
in fact they're the inverse of
fashionable in some sense but are
desperately needed and so you might say
humility uh dutifulness uh careful
emotional self-regulation
discretion uh the antithesis of
narcissism all of that and she managed
it extraordinarily well for 70 years and
so whenever things go too far in One
Direction there's a tremendous
unconscious or implicit desire for
something that would set it right and
that's what you saw happen and not only
on on the personal front but there's
also all the Pomp and ceremony which is
also archaic and and unfashionable that
was all part of that that you Brits
managed so spectacularly that was all
people are just dying for that for that
for that beauty was I felt like the
country before this happened two weeks
before it felt like the whole country
was in a shambolic state that everything
was going wrong in our country and in a
way the death of the queen unified us in
a way we hadn't been for a long time
yeah certainly since brexit
um no one was talking about hot button
political issues or social issues
they're all talking about one thing I
mean it also reinforced our national
identity oh yeah in a way they actually
made the world look on with great awe
about the procession our military our
royal family the country it made people
feel good about Britain again yeah and
therefore made British people feel good
about themselves again yeah well you
guys have lots to feel good about and
that's not the standard Mantra of the
modern world you know this is an
unbelievably admirable country for all
its flaws and so what do you find out
about us
English common law
the the the tradition of free speech uh
sardonic and self-effacing humor that so
much a part of the culture
the our ability to cue for 13 hours
politely to see a woman lying a study is
not even a member of our family
resilience going to do that peacefully
and to do that in the spirit of mutual
Goodwill and come to a place like London
it's unbelievably
ethnically diverse and yet it functions
extraordinarily well and what are your
best traits and what are the the worst
traits of Dr Jordan Peterson
well I think that it's been difficult
for me to to optimally regulate my
irritation at times over the last few
years
and I'm trying to get that right to
figure out what the right because a lot
of things that have happened have
outraged me and then I'm not exactly
sure what emotional tone to take as a
consequence of that outrage and that's a
very complicated thing to figure out and
that's been exacerbated that problem by
the fact that I have been my family and
I have been the targets of very
conniving
um and and attacks and underground
attacks and that isn't stopping I mean
another time when your wife was fighting
a deadly cancer yeah
so was I so yeah yeah so it's very
difficult to regulate your your temper
properly under those circumstances let's
say and so I don't imagine where have
you most improved yourself do you think
as you've got older
I get better and better at listening you
know and I'm better and better at
finding my way forward with the words
that I choose and that's just it's just
a continual in some sense incremental
expansion I probably got better too at
seeking out corrective information so
for example I got banned from Twitter
recently for making a statement that I
don't regret by the way but I had a
friend of mine two friends of mine Grill
me and I put that on YouTube it's called
Mean Tweets the it was an hour and a
half I said and one of them both of them
are very very smart people one of them
is more liberal than I am I would say
and but a very good advocate for that
liberal position and I I said well let's
hash this out there's some things I've
said that have made people angry and you
think I made them unnecessarily angry
and that I was unnecessarily harsh in my
tone did they change your mind
they changed my Approach you know
because one of the things I decided was
that I would try to be equally
judicious in my words but that I would
use a calmer and more measured tone and
I don't mean use instrumentally I mean
that I would attempt to make the effort
to take as much unnecessary emotion out
of the
statement as possible and so I started
to do that in some of my more recent
videos I mean I tried to do that before
I think part of the reason that my
interview with Kathy Newman went well
was because I kept my head and I didn't
get irritated she's a good friend of
mine and I watched it with great
interest because I felt like you were
slightly on parallel lines and that
maybe she would do that interview
differently if she had her time again I
think that's highly possible yeah so so
yes I I changed my Approach quite
dramatically and what happened was that
I I read a telegraph article I recently
published about Deloitte and it was a
very cutting article and I was really
worried about publishing it because I
think it was the most cutting article
I've ever written and I read it on
YouTube very very calmly and carefully
and what happened was
I got
the response was much more positive and
much less negative so there was no
downside to it so people didn't say some
people said I you know I think that I
like your tone when you were more
aggressive especially on issues like
this but by and large it had all it
worked even better because I could be
careful in what I was discriminating and
then to Ally that with calmness actually
made it more potent rather than less and
so that was very interesting and yeah
and I mean we had a very serious
discussion about this my friends and I I
had a lot of people with me in Miami
when this was happening across the
political Spectrum made a very healthy
debate for a couple of hours about
whether or not I had gone
Beyond some reasonable limit in the way
I was conducting myself Say on YouTube
and Twitter and some people were very
strongly advocating for more of what I
was doing and even harsher and others
were saying well you're alienating
people that you could otherwise
communicate with them it's interesting
about the listening like one of my sons
too my sons had come today because
that's one of the listen to this very
unusual one of them's not even been to
the studio before so he just said to me
I said give me some advice you know you
love Jordan Peterson what's the advice
for the interview he said just listen
more than you normally do so I've tried
I've tried hard to ask a question and
let you answer right and so I'm work in
progress and I've been interviewing
people for 35 years but I do think the
listening as I've got older I've felt
the same thing that there's a real skill
man this thing is a is a powerful tool
actually oh yeah well there isn't people
there is nothing that people like more
and need more than to be listened to you
know and that's partly why the left
clamors all the time you know it says
look there's all these people who aren't
being listened to it's like there are a
lot of people who aren't being listened
to they're absolutely right there's no
doubt about that and I've dealt with
people who were extraordinarily
marginalized so to speak in my clinical
practice and some of those people to
straighten out their minds they need
like 10 000 hours of listening because
no one and I mean this literally I've
had people in my clinical practice
no one ever listened to them their whole
life yeah and so when you they start
talking they're all over the place
they're disorganized they're hyper
emotional having met me enough for an
hour what would your initial clinical
diagnosis be well you're probably
optimally disagreeable for your for your
profession you know because you can
listen but you're also not a pushover
and that's a very that's a very fine
line right because if you're too
assertive or aggressive then you get
domineering but if you're not enough
then you're a pushover and to be and
this was also the case with Kathy Newman
she's quite disagreeable and that's
that's a masculine trait by the way and
it was one of the things I think
mentioned into it in a ways where we
started the interview she'd gone into I
think with a preconceived idea of what
you would be like and sort of stuck to
that yeah it's actually a very skillful
journalist and interviewer and I was
surprised the way that interview went
when I was watching it I think it was
because she just had an idea of what she
thought you would be well I think she
probably really I think she also had an
outcome an idea of what the optimal
outcome of the interview might be and I
think a lot of the journalists who've
gone after me in some sense have that
they think they there's part of them and
thinks all I'll be the person that
finally exposes him for what he is but
then they find out that I'm not who they
thought they that I at least I'm not
quite as demonic as they thought I might
be well Professor Stephen Hawking before
he died gave me his last television
interview and he said the the biggest
threat to the future of mankind was when
artificial intelligence learned to
self-design what do you think the
biggest threat to mankind is
narcissistic compassion
now ai's you know it's a threat too but
if we if we're if we had our act
together ethically
it's possible that AI could become a
useful servant rather than a tyrannical
master
you don't want to automate your
tyrannical Masters and that's the danger
that's one of the dangers of AI
I've got to wrap it up I don't want to
but I have to I want to ask you just
quickly uh the film director Olivia
Wilde has a new movie out which she says
it's based on you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men uh who are despicable in many
ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized we're
supposed to have a voice
it's making emotional to talk about it
well God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it that's all oh by
that time you know
that as far as as critic critiques go
that was kind of low level I mean once I
got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
there's no place past that so when
Olivia Wilde made those comments the
first thing I did was go look at the
preview for a movie which I quite liked
I thought I would go see that movie
probably and perhaps I will it didn't
really bother me my my family and I
talked about it right away and we were
able to respond to it with some degree
of humor which then people completely
misunderstood I said I hope that you
know that if I had to be played by
someone
he's a very good looking man and so that
seems all right you know and then I said
something like I hope he gets my my uh
fashion style choice right when he plays
me and it was a joke all that was a joke
you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
it's really something to see
constantly
how many people
are dying for lack of an encouraging
word
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
and to say
you're in net force for good if you want
to be
do you believe you're not full so good
net yes
in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much
you thank you you've got this new box
set up yeah yeah I'm pretty happy about
that we pay just 24 rules for life uh
and Beyond order uh fascinating books
they sold how many millions now well 12
rules sold seven and I think Beyond
order is approaching a million now so
yeah they're doing just fine you ever
think you'd sell that number of books I
never thought any of this would happen
you know I mean
so I knew when I was teaching at Harvard
and at University of Toronto that some
of the things I were I was teaching were
revolutionary I was surprised that I got
along with it got away with it let's say
as long as I did
and so it didn't see there's a way in
which it doesn't surprise me and and I
wouldn't say that's because of the
Brilliance of my ideas it's because I'm
I'm good at communicating ideas but the
ideas that I've been developing their
ancient ideas they're the oldest ideas
we have in some real sense they have the
power right absolutely and just finally
you're healthy you look healthy
pretty good much better your wife's
doing a lot better than she was
she's back better than she was before
even and my daughter is not ill either
so fancy that I mean that's an amazing
turnaround from where you work that's
for sure man it was pretty
brutal yeah
for a long time you know my wife almost
died every day for seven months
so
I'm very glad for you thank you sir I
really am it's been a really a
fascinating interview appreciate your
time come back it's a pleasure to see
you I feel like we've got a million more
things I could talk to you about which
I'm sure everyone thinks that when they
talk to you well that's a good that's a
good thing to have happen during an
interview thank you you bet man
one extraordinary interview with an
extraordinary character uh whatever you
think of Jordan Peterson you can't
listen to that and not be enthralled
captivated maybe challenged maybe you
don't agree with him I'm not sure he
Minds if you disagree with him that's
the whole point
it's about stimulating ideas it's about
challenging what you believe evolving
as we both do as we've got older that's
it for me whatever you're up to keep it
uncensored
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign